[Music]
and you're watching this in english
chances are you belong to the world's
bilingual and multilingual majority
and besides having an easier time
traveling or watching movies without
subtitles
knowing two or more languages means that
your brain may actually look
and work differently than those of your
monolingual friends
so what does it really mean to know a
language
language ability is typically measured
in two active parts
speaking and writing and two passive
parts listening and reading
while a balanced bilingual has near
equal abilities across the board in two
languages
most bilinguals around the world know
and use their languages
in varying proportions and depending on
their situation
and how they acquired each language they
can be classified into three general
types
for example let's take gabriella whose
family immigrates to the u.s from peru
when she's two years old
as a compound bilingual gabriella
develops
two linguistic codes simultaneously with
a single set of concepts
learning both english and spanish as she
begins to process the world around her
her teenage brother on the other hand
might be a coordinate bilingual
working with two sets of concepts
learning english in school
while continuing to speak spanish at
home and with friends
finally gabriella's parents are likely
to be subordinate bilinguals
who learn a secondary language by
filtering it through their primary
language
because all types of bilingual people
can become fully proficient in a
language
regardless of accent or pronunciation
the difference may not be apparent to a
casual observer
but recent advances in brain imaging
technology
have given neural linguists a glimpse
into how specific aspects of language
learning
affect the bilingual brain it's well
known that the brain's
left hemisphere is more dominant in
analytical and logical processes
while the right hemisphere is more
active in emotional and social ones
though this is a matter of degree not an
absolute split
the fact that language involves both
types of functions
while lateralization develops gradually
with age
has led to the critical period
hypothesis according to this theory
children learn languages more easily
because the plasticity of their
developing brains
lets them use both hemispheres in
language acquisition
while in most adults language is
lateralized to one hemisphere
usually the left if this is true
learning a language in childhood may
give you a more holistic grasp of its
social and emotional contexts conversely
recent research showed
that people who learned a second
language in adulthood
exhibit less emotional bias and a more
rational approach when confronting
problems in the second language
than in their native one but regardless
of when you acquire additional languages
being multilingual gives your brain some
remarkable advantages
some of these are even visible such as
higher density of the gray matter that
contains most of your brain's neurons
and synapses
and more activity in certain regions
when engaging a second language
the heightened workout a bilingual brain
receives throughout its life
can also help delay the onset of
diseases like alzheimer's and dementia
by as much as five years
the idea of major cognitive benefits to
bilingualism
may seem intuitive now but it would have
surprised earlier experts
before the 1960s bilingualism was
considered a handicap
that slowed a child's development by
forcing them to spend too much energy
distinguishing between languages a view
based largely on flawed studies
and while a more recent study did show
that reaction times and errors increase
for some bilingual students in
cross-language tests
it also showed that the effort and
attention needed to switch between
languages
triggered more activity in and
potentially strengthened
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex this
is the part of the brain that plays a
large role in executive function
problem solving switching between tasks
and focusing while filtering out
irrelevant information
so while bilingualism may not
necessarily make you smarter
it does make your brain more healthy
complex and actively engaged
and even if you didn't have the good
fortune of learning a second language as
a child
it's never too late to do yourself a
favor and make the linguistic leap
from hello to hola bonjour or nihals
because when it comes to our brains a
little exercise can go a long way
[Music]
you